[Musique]
16h15 c'est la fin des cours cette école
secondaire de rouyn noranda
mais la journée est loin d'être terminée
pour louis charles chauvette mais rentre
chez lui va se changer puis sa mère ne
reconduit au travail
j'avais rien afin que j'ai travaillé
puis beige et j'ai léché traverse persie
du haut de ses 12 ans l'élève de
secondaire 1 et caissier dans une
épicerie son horaire du lundi au
vendredi de 17 à 21h un total de 20
heures par semaine si jusqu'à rec puis
comme ceux mais ça me permet de faire
des activités à fonctionner
est ce qu'il ya des journées où tu dion
ou là je suis fatigué le nom nom
ou le la main à l'école carte
affinitaire bac atteignant 9 heures est
ce que parce que des fois qu'il a mais
les causes difficiles
avec la pénurie main d'oeuvre de
nombreux employeurs se tourner vers les
jeunes pour combler les postes vacants
on voit de plus en plus d'adolescentes
12 13 14 ans au travail dans les
restaurants et les commerces
à la recherche d'un premier emploi
matteo dérive s'est fait embaucher dans
cette boucherie une annonce facebook que
j'avais vu justement où est ce que
cherchait quelqu un accueil si vous
voyez mon conjoint quand il l'a vue
parce que mathéou était vraiment pas
grand l'époque et tous appuyé aux jeunes
déterminés et je peux pas pour l'engager
l'adolescent qui vient tout juste
d'avoir 13 ans a travaillé ici pendant
six mois de juin jusqu'à la fin de son
contrat en novembre une façon de gagner
un peu d'argent ou de combler ses temps
libres
socialiser avec les gens contexte de
pandémie y ait des choses comme si
c'était un sujet justement piet avoir
une petite source de revenu justement
cité qu'est ce que tu as fait avec
l'argent alors que tu veux refaire ou
ben j'en ai pas mis un peu sécheresse et
je fais des dépenses avec seul ce qui me
reste son travail a été grandement
appréciée et où il était très social
très avenant avec les clients donc ça
allait super bien pire moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup surpris personnellement c'est
que ils savaient qu'en me connaissait
déjà un peu la viande cuisinée on voyait
qu'ils n'étaient pas jeanne et d'aller
au devant des clients et leur proposer
des choses il n'y a pas d'âge minimal
pour travailler au québec les enfants de
moins de 14 ans doivent cependant avoir
une autorisation écrite de leurs parents
le père de matteo n'a pas hésité le
travail peu poussif c'est pô juste que
je pose qui est ennuyant publié droit au
meilleur moyen de faire quelque chose
qu'on puisse réaliser qu'on peut
dépasser qu'on peut apprendre compo du
plaisir à faire plier fiers de nous puis
mettez où était rendu donne les jeunes
québécois travaillent de plus en plus le
taux d'emploi chez des étudiants de 15 à
19 ans a pratiquement doublé en 20 ans
pour atteindre 38 % en 2018 les données
sont plus rares pour les jeunes de moins
de 15 ans selon une étude publiée en
2000 16 6 % des élèves de secondaire 1
travaille chez un employeur qui n'est
pas une entreprise familiale c'est 11%
pour les élèves de secondaire 2
mais en abitibi témiscamingue
ces taux sont deux fois plus élevés que
la moyenne nationale ce qu'on voit ce
qu'on entasse le qu'effectivement les
jeunes rentrent sur le marché du travail
de plus en plus jeunes
12 ans 13 ans travailler dès un jeune
âge peut avoir de bons côtés comme
développer son autonomie sa
débrouillardise
améliorer son estime de soi mais il faut
tenter de maintenir un équilibre avec
les études ou delà de 15 heures semaine
ça commence à faire beaucoup
les risques c'est des risques
d'épuisement de diminution du rendement
à l'école ou au travail la fatigue qui
s'accumule le plus grand risque le sait
le risque de décrochage scolaire parce
que se passe rien d'avoir une job avec
un salaire pour pouvoir s'acheter des
choses ça permet ni de désavantage les
fait travailler en parallèle aux études
également même s'ils sont quelques
heures par semaine ça peut améliorer la
réussite et la persévérance donc c'est
l'équilibré pendant l'été choisi à peu
près du trois jours semaine on aurait
dit mercredi samedi qui est
1 pendant l'école je faisais juste le
samedi en fait j'avais mon sport le
matin et puis je voulais travailler
l'après-midi de faire une demi journée
par semaine comme ça durant l'étude à
12,1 on est vraiment très confortable
avec son mari ma blonde les boucheries
ben était quand même très consciente
quand elle était jeune il est étudiant
qui le travail numéro de matériaux c'est
être étudiées comme il a apprécié sa
première expérience m'a t on s'est
trouvé un autre emploi à la billetterie
d'un centre de ski les week-ends une
dizaine de ses amis ont aussi un travail
c'est un accent qui sont parents tu n'en
as copie scarlett qui aurions pas passer
mais il y en a d'autres qui la plupart
de mes amis une source de revenu sur
tout et qu'ils voulaient qui est surtout
moi je pense que leur fait des
techniques et pied moi je pense savoir
que mateo geste est même pu aller
travailler
parce que t'encourager qu'est ce que tu
avais
je le mets dans un autre compte pige
l'économiste pour mais qu'est pour plus
tard ici olivier vachon radio canada
rouyn noranda
[Musique]